So far what we've done is call the recognizer task.
We have a function match which takes a pattern and a text,
and that returns back a substring of text if it matches or None.
It's called a recognizer, because we're recognizing whether the prefix of text
is in the language defined by the pattern.
There's a whole other task called the generator in which we generate from a pattern
a complete language defined by that pattern.
For example, the pattern a or b sequenced with a or b.
That defines a language of four different strings--,
and we could define a function that takes a pattern and generates out that language.
That all seems fine. One problem, though.
If we have a language like a then the answer of that should be the empty string
or a or aa or aaa and so on. It's an infinite set.
That's a problem. How are we going to represent this infinite set?
Now, it's possible. We could have a generator function that generates the items one at a time.
That's a pretty good interface, but instead I'm going to have one
where we say let's limit the sizes of the strings we want.
If we say we want all strings up to n characters in length,
then that's always going to be a finite set.
I'm going to take the compiler approach.
Rather than write a function "generate," I'm going to have the generator
be compiled into the patterns.
What we're going to write is a pattern, which is a compiled function,
and we're going to apply that to a set of integers representing the possible range
of lengths that we want to retrieve.
That's going to return a set of strings.
So for example, if we define pattern to be a--we did that appropriately--
and then we asked for pattern, and w gave it the set .
Then that should return all strings which are derived from the pattern that have a length 1, 2, or 3.
So that should be the set .
Now let's go ahead and implement this.